hello everybody hello bond there's a man
who ruffle up here good evening all my
Academy friends and others in Hollywood
I'm sorry I can't be with you I have
other things to do not more important
but I have other commitments in London
which keeps me here I know that you'll
be celebrating tonight 50 years and for
me if they're 50 wonderful years were
born not that I was in them for 50 years
but I feel the music has been with me
for 50 years we are a great deal in the
Bond films to to the music the wonderful
themes and to the songs of a connected
with the films for example Live and Let
Die Paul McCartney in his best in George
Martin with his best Arrangements ever
and of course Marvin Hamlisch who I can
remember it 3 o'clock one morning in
hotel room in in London where he
insisted on playing me nobody does it
better and I must say nobody did it
better than he and of course the
wonderful John Berry of all those
wonderful wonderful themes that he wrote
it occurred to me the other day that of
course John Barry is not with us anymore
and neither is Marvin Hamlisch I'm sorry
to say for your sake then hi I am still
here but I hope to be around for a lot
more to hear you humming the songs as
you go out tonight good night